that's when they let you bring food and
feed the animals too so my dad would
bring Al Madrigal would take in a huge
bag of Granny Smith apples and just
throw it just Chuck them right into the
bear's mouth
feeding the Bears so the Bears
throwing fastballs into a bear's mouth
because this guy right here is throwing
a fastball a high fastball into the
Granny's the guy behind your dad's got
two buckets of KFC when you're done man
Chuck this chicken out and see what
happens what about the bones what about
them they like the bone no one
monitoring that at all that was the same
Zoo where the kids snuck in and uh stole
the koalas too at Christmas to give to
their girlfriends that's nobody's
written a book about the free-for-all
that was the San Francisco Zoo